everyone welcome back to game Sports
coverage of e3 2017 joining Oscar and
myself is Xavier he'd talk about Mario
Plus Rabbids Kingdom battle David
welcome thank you what's what's the
reception been like cuz I was a huge
surprise at a us us press conference
it's been tremendous you know we've been
working on this game like in the cave
for more than three years we can talk
about the project and then being at e3
today to talk about it with a team the
dev team as well and to see people
playing the game is just amazing
what I love is it's sort of two
incredible franchises coming together
did you go to Nintendo first or didn't
Nintendo reach out and say they wanted
to work with you how did it come about
so we started to work on this prototype
an idea and we felt you know this could
work because we're big turn-based game
fans and we felt that mixing Mario and
the rabbits with original something that
we didn't see in the past with Mario
would be great so we went in Japan and
we started to talk about this we
presented the prototype we went missing
with mr. Miyamoto and his team and it
was incredible because we could see in
their eyes as well that this was new
different even the prototype was quite
similar in terms of the combat that we
see today
of course the graphics and all the
animation were not there but it was
really a tremendous moment and and since
then we started to work hand in hand
with them so I'm sorry how do you Trump
how do you go about trying to mix the
two art styles together because they are
so different but then like I can't
imagine the amount of discussions that
needed to be had to get to try and
amalgamate the two completely different
art styles and also licenses together
like I that must have been such a
nightmare trying to get that sorted
right so you know we are big fans of
Mario obviously so I think the first
step was already to show the respect we
have for Mario in terms of animation in
terms of art also in terms of design and
that was a first step
are we all ready to show that we know
those games we love those games and were
able to show prototypes showing that
Mario and his friends can be something
that we can work with but it was not
enough because it was really clear
from Nintendo said as well that we had
to be surprising we have to add this
twist and as a rabbits are pretty good
with you know crossovers we did very man
in the past and they're good to you know
put contrasts on the table so when we
started to have those ideas of you know
doing those combos super effects with
those weapons and it was a bit crazy
also to have a weapon in Mario's hands
and rabbits hands but it was this touch
there was you know triggering interest
and they wanted to see how far we could
go so then in terms of animation for
example it's really different between
the two you know Mario cannot stretch
that much compared to the rabbits
they're really different in terms of
animation so we were wondering if you
know the mix would go on and be
interesting and and we're super happy
with the result because we believe it
really fits together well and and so far
it seems that players are really happy
to see those two things together what I
love as well is that it seems like the
rabbits are poking fun in a loving way
towards Mario and you know peach you
have a rabbit peach how is that sort of
like was it you guys able to sort of
write a love letter to Mario in your own
game so at the being is true that we
wanted to create this contrast between
the two so even if it's rabbit peach
it's not just peach in a rabbit form we
wanted to you know have a personality
and on its own and so there's a big part
in the game where they interact together
for example Morial + rabbit Mario and
the right mario is super proud of Mario
but he wants to do too much like you
would go way too far you want to be like
Mario but he's not Mario obviously so
this interaction was really keep one of
the the game in terms of story but also
in terms of combat so rabbit Mario and
combat is really dangerous even for the
other heroes he goes way too far in the
skills and the way he attacks so he's a
more advanced player and hero so this is
something that we wanted to have as well
in the combat system to be quite
irrelevant in terms of relationship so
what happens when if you
when you take out a rabbit or if they
manage to take out one of your guys I
guess it's not like you're not gonna
introduce desk that kind of seems
doesn't seem like it would fit it
doesn't really go through yeah way to
have Mario dying right like I mean yeah
that would be weird
yeah like one up and stuff in like one
more life but so we have of course we
have a lot of rules on Mario's side with
what we discussed with Nintendo
we cannot do everything of yesterday and
the rabbits are pretty much the same we
don't see normally rabbits dying so what
we decided to do anyway was linked to
the storyline when you defeat an enemy
he's not dying he's just being
teleported as a white rabbit in the hub
and that's why the hub evolves
throughout the game is as you defeat
more and more enemies they get to
construct stuff in the hub so you never
kill anyone and we just saw de-rezzed
rabbit here you just get teleported into
the hub and we prefer to have this fun
approach even though what weapons then
going in you know a very realistic mode
and it wasn't really not the angle we
wanted to go for yeah so how are the
rabbits and Mario and Peach and Yoshi
how are they getting together in the
story so basically at the beginning of
the game they just arrived in Mushroom
Kingdom because they use the washing
time machine
and usually they go you know in the
period of time randomly and this time
they landed in the Mushroom Kingdom
Mario has no clue what a rabbit is so
when he sees rabbit peach and rabbit
liji is just you know a shock and
contrast and the rabbits they don't
really care about saving someone or the
world they just follow Mario because
he's funny and maybe it's going to be a
fun adventure and that's it and then of
course you'll get to unlock new heroes
so you don't get the eight heroes are
being in the game you get them as you go
into the adventure and then the rabbit
starts to interact way more into the
adventure itself so what's the what's
the structure of the game because I
gather there's a large exploration
element as well right in just just the
strategic combat inside like um is there
a hub world or like how do you move
from level to level yeah so one thing
they didn't destroy when they arrived in
the game was beach castle
so peach castle and surroundings are
acting as the hub of the game so
basically go in each world thanks to
cannons that were created and then it's
a mix between exploration and combat
turn-based combat so an exploration you
have puzzles you have secret zones you
have things you can discover as well
sideways for new weapons you know new
orbs for your skill tree and then we
have of course the combats so that's a
big part of the concept but we wanted to
avoid having combat after combat and
just feel like you know doing fight over
fights and even though it's a huge part
of the game we truly wanted to have an
adventure so that's the part where you
have exploration coming in so that's
pretty much the structure right we
talked a little bit a little little blue
rumba guy who they're following around
beep oh so that's the name we gave him
so this guy's a fusion between an AI and
rabbit he's able to understand what the
rabbits are saying and even Mario so
like a translator yeah he's like his
translator but he's lost most of the
game is a bit lost he's trying to show
it as in control but in fact he's lost
because it doesn't understand how
unpredictable the rabbits can be in the
end and he doesn't understand why the
world is going so crazy with the the
chaos and and so he's trying to act as a
translator but he's also key for the
game itself because in combat he's
acting as you know the cursor he's
helping you to give you tips at being of
the game he's there to tell you pretty
much what is happening around trying to
explain to the player was happening on
the screen so is that almost like a sort
of help to the player I mean I was going
to ask about how difficult it was to try
and transport Mario into what until now
is a complete completely new genre for
him you know that probably a lot of
Mario fans out there and a lot of rabid
fans out there that might not have
played in these kinds of strategic games
before so is is that character is that
the purely Celtics players oh yeah yeah
it's true that it's a new type of game
for potentially mini Mario fans and
we're the players we wanted to have when
we're big fan of games like XCOM like
other turn-based games as well RPGs we
have a lot of influences but we also had
a lot of ideas to bring into the mix and
we felt with Mario on the rabbits one
thing for sure you need to be accessible
you know you can't have walls of things
that takes time controls that could be
complex as well so we wanted to have
like an experience is really accessible
but not simple of course at the being of
the game we're teaching you how to move
how to do action in your movement phase
attack phase different type of weapons
with your techniques defensive ones
offensive ones but then it starts to
ramp up and with a combo system where
you can add up actions as you go into
the game it becomes something
interesting where you have to make
choices a lot into the combat game part
but one thing also was important was to
avoid being a game where you need to
think six seven eight moves ahead
that could be complicated and complex we
prefer to go for reacting every turn to
what is happening here we see a burner
plant it's a mid boss you can burn you
and you're out of cover and maybe this
was not planned so you have to adapt the
next turn and try to find a better
strategy now that you're out of cover so
it's an important part to be able to
react to what is happening with the
tools that you have yeah so how did you
I mean you mentioned that the piranha
plant that can burn you when you're in
cover mmm
was that a case of like what came first
there did you think of the burning
element person and and then think what
Mario character can we put in this or
was it like oh the piranha plant is a
really cool character what ability can
we try and create out of that and
Transplant into this world it's a really
good question because piranha plan was a
big brainstorm actually when we started
it's the first midboss we thought of and
you know perón plan in mario world are
always north korean fire so it came
quickly into fact that hey we want to
have super effects what about giving you
a AOE type of attack to this midboss
that could be a good reference to where
the character is and in fact we applied
that to the wall mid
and bosses fights that we have in the
game so I won't spoil too much about you
know all the heroes and enemies were
using from Mario's world but yes every
time we did that we use you know their
specifics it is that we know and there's
their games and we apply that to the
system we just saw that is collecting
coins mid encounter what do they do do
they give you bonuses in this encounter
or is it just a collectible to pick up
later yeah it's a collectible you have
for buying weapons basically so when you
destroy cover you get a coin so it's
still interesting to destroy cover for
that reason as well when you do a golden
shot which means a huge damage output
and defeat the enemy you get golden
coins as well as a huge amount of golden
coins so those are super useful for
buying weapons afterwards so if you're
good in combat you do the right decision
and get a lot of coins you go faster to
get new weapons
is there any punishment for players I
mean like you're saying early it has to
be accessible right so and be harsh too
you know when I think of XCOM I have
hard core that can be on like Ironman
mode is it do you have to sort of rein
that back in to accommodate players who
might not be so familiar with this kind
of genre so we wanted to have a game
accessible for everyone everyone can
play and at first it gives you the basis
and it's an approachable you know
experience compared to other return
based games but then in ramp up quickly
so you need to level up your game quite
fast so that you're really using those
basics but then you have to apply them
to where more strategy within the game
but we felt we're pretty proud now the
evolution because then you really use
those tools but it doesn't become more
complex it just because you have more
decisions to take within the fights but
then we shuffle everything up because
here we see no burn covers explosive
covers but later on you can have you
know indestructible covers that are
really useful because you can get behind
it but then you have also other side
effects like push bounds or ink ink you
cannot do any technique for one turn ink
you cannot attack for one turn so it's a
bit more advanced
but if you mix and match those covers
together plus the pipes plus the enemies
doing different type of attacks plus the
combo system for example rabbit pshh can
triple - mid-game instead of just
dashing once so Mario can team stump you
can jump on the head of the enemy after
a team jump we G can do a three pole
team jump so it expands own even more so
you get more and more option which is
cool but at the same time you have to
make those right decisions because the
enemy are getting stronger and they have
more tools as well for example we have a
Smasher type of archetype that we call
those guys attack you as soon as you
attack them even if it's not as there is
turn and it teaches you that attacking
is good but sometimes maybe not the best
choice so we go progressively and then
on this side we also have challenges so
when you finish a world can come back
and you have some challenges rabbit Todd
give you challenges and they're meant to
be more a bit more hardcore for example
you have to finish off 15 enemies in one
round so you need to think ahead in tune
sort of weapons super attacks mix and
matching those and even at the end of
the game where else playing too much we
have ultimate challenges there let's say
even higher level in terms of challenge
we saw the use of press conference when
the game was announced obviously had mr.
Miyamoto come out and your creative
director got very emotional is a really
lovely moment to watch what's that
experience been like sort of working
with someone like Miyamoto it's been
amazing we saw many times mr. Miyamoto
and his team in Japan obviously to talk
about the project and progression but
seeing him while we announced the game
already the emotion was high announcing
the game itself to see how people would
react to the concept react to the game
ja react to the everything about the
game it was already high in terms of
emotion and then having mr. Miyamoto on
stage looking at Devi VA the team he
knows the team and it was a connection
we could feel it in the room it was
tremendous in a moment amazing moment
for everyone
and we could feel it inside a room so
yes it was very high emotion moment and
also we could you know feel the love in
the room itself just showing the
gameplay finally the gameplay how it
looks how it plays explain a little bit
about the basics we knew we had the demo
for e3 as well just behind we could have
those pods people playing it so we're
just yeah the team the dev team of
course was crazy in Paris in media and
the one in the room itself alright
alright well thank you so much for
joining thank you when can we play Mario
plus retro end of August August 29th
not long to wait yeah I know oh wow you
guys must be so excited to finally have
it up very excited thank you for joining
you thank you guys for more from this
year's e3 make sure you don't go
anywhere stay tuned to games.com